i still remember that day very well how
disappointed and frustrated i was when i
couldn't clear my pmp exam in my first
attempt
initially i took an offline class at a
nearby center but i couldn't clear my
pmp certification i was traveling five
to six hours a day daily from home to
work soon i realized i need to take pmp
course online with good course content
and also instructors so that i can clear
the certification
my brother and friends strongly
recommended simply learn and i'm glad
that i made that as my final choice hi
i'm hari babaji i completed my be in
electrical and electronics engineering
from university of madras and i also
pursued my mba in international business
from pondicherry university i work as a
project manager at ncr corporation india
private limited for the past 12 years i
signed up for the simply learns pmp
program and i reappeared for the pmp
exam again i cleared my pmp
certification in the second attempt
after completing my course with simply
learn i was given more project
management responsibilities at work and
i was also elevated from the current
position of assistant manager
manufacturing engineering into a project
manager with a decent salary hike
the simply learn course helped me to
learn project management in a very
structured way and that helped me a lot
in my current responsibilities handling
i.t infrastructure projects as well as
the erp projects in my current
organization so with that success story
of pmp certification i also added on
itil certification to my profile from
simply learn again very proudly now i
can claim that i'm a pmp and itil
certified professional
above all i am a pmi board member for
the pmi chennai chapter due to my family
commitments i had to travel for five to
six hours a day to and fro from home to
work therefore the mobile app was very
helpful for me and i was able to prepare
any time anywhere for my pmp exam
preparation i love spending time with my
family and i am also passionate about
maintaining my garden the monetary
benefits that i received through this
career growth opportunity helped me
easily gather funds for my sister's
marriage as well as invest on my kids
education now i can confidently say that
simply learn is the best online training
partner for anyone's career growth